we're learning more tonight about a
deadly car crash at speeds alleged to be
over 100 miles per hour a man is dead
after being hit by a car in midtown
it's just tragic the crash happened on
the 10 freeway in fontana killing four
people
investigators tell us there is a
possibility that this was the result of
a dui
eyewitnesses say it appeared the driver
didn't realize he had struck the boy and
his mother
until it was too late these are only a
few of the estimated 38
800 deaths on american streets in 2019
and possibly even more tragically we
actually have the technology to prevent
many of those deaths
we're just not using it
[Music]
this is david zipper he's a visiting
fellow at the harvard kennedy school
and first wrote about this technology
for city lab what is the risk for
people in the united states um for car
fatalities
what what has been the trend there well
it's not been good
in the last decade in america overall
road and street fatalities have been
relatively flat
but that masks some big differences if
you're inside of an automobile
it's actually gotten safer fatalities
have gone down over the last decade
but they've spiked for pedestrians and
for cyclists between 30 and 45
over the last decade and meanwhile if
you compare the united states to other
uh oecd countries other western
countries especially in europe
we're doing much worse in helsinki
finland last year there were literally
zero deaths
and those risks are not spread out
evenly in fact those most likely to be
killed
as a cyclist or a pedestrian they tend
to be minorities they tend to be elderly
they often are low income so this is
actually an equity issue
as much as a safety one
many city governments have worked hard
to address these issues adopting safer
street initiatives around improving
crosswalks and lowering speed limits but
those measures can only go so far
the reality is when two tons
of glass metal and plastic hit
150 pounds of flesh and bone
it's the human who's gonna lose every
single time
this is another david david friedman and
he's the vice president for advocacy at
consumer reports
you know one of the things we just did
recently was we put out a report
that pointed out that we could actually
cut them roadway fatalities in half
with technologies that are already out
there today
well let's talk about speed in a big
country like the united states
speed cells people like it and car
companies play off of
those sorts of ideas that an automobile
lets you go
quickly and independently i'm reminded
of an advertisement for the dodge
charger that i saw
myself when i was watching the super
bowl a few years ago it's
a wonderful thing this game really plays
on these ideas of being american
to bring an entire nation together and
being loyal
glorious moment in time
we are thankful mainly because the
streets are just
empty as hell right now
[Music]
it was really striking to me and i think
it it is very revealing about how
automobiles sell this concept of speed
urban speed in particular through their
products
i mean when you sort of look back at
history the automobile
really showed up in american cities it
changed the speed of the street
that's selita reynolds all right let's
do it she's the general manager for the
los angeles department of transportation
and as she explains lowering the speed
of vehicles can dramatically shift
fatality rates
if you are hit by a car that is
traveling
20 miles an hour or slower you have
a 80 to 90 percent chance of
surviving that crash if you're on foot
once that car is going
40 miles an hour your chance of
surviving that crash plummets
down to about 20 percent
cities throughout the united states have
been really trying
to keep especially vulnerable
pedestrians and cyclists safe
by reducing speed limits or encouraging
drivers
to go slower the problem is that
they can violate that speed limit
however there is a technological
solution
a simple device called a speed governor
or a speed limiter
the speed governors have been around for
literally over a century
today you can have a speed governor that
is pretty simple saying
you know the vehicle can never go above
40 miles an hour or you can have a quote
unquote smart speed governor
that would adjust to the surrounding
speed limit
are there any laws in the books or is
there any government action to sort of
put these in cars well no
the united states there's really been no
effort
to require or even encourage speed
limiters speed governors to be installed
on personal vehicles in europe
regulators have been more aggressive
all new vehicles bought and sold at the
european
union from the year 2022 will have to be
fitted
with a so-called intelligence speed
assistance technology
the speed governors there are going to
be smart and that they will
use data from a variety of different
sources to adjust
based on what the surrounding speed
limit is but
and this may end up being a big but a
driver will be able to overcome
the limit by keeping a foot pressed down
on the accelerator
that may be helpful for a driver who
wants to say get around a truck on the
highway
but it does open questions about just
how much protection will be afforded
to pedestrians and cyclists from a truly
reckless driver
but there are technologies out there
that can help prevent some of the most
dangerous drivers
from ever even taking the wheel a woman
suspected of driving
under the influence is dead this morning
after driving
many roadway fatalities occur within a
quarter mile
of a pub bar drinking establishment
which means either the driver or the
pedestrian or sometimes both
have been impaired this is greg winfrey
the director of the texas a
m transportation institute and he points
to one maybe obvious technology
the breathalyzer breathalyzers are
typically
used to ensure compliance
from folks that have been convicted of a
drunk driving offense you know so
there's stigma what i want to
voluntarily
put on my vehicle a device that to a
passerby
might say this guy is a dui guy
the auto industry with some regulators
has been developing some new
technologies
a program called dads or d-a-d-s-s
that would actually look at a driver's
breath
or their touch on the steering wheel to
be able to passively determine
if there's alcohol in their system and
then frankly they wouldn't be able to
operate the vehicle
that technology is still a few years
away but there's other types of
technology being developed as well
that have a similar goal these
technologies fall into what are known as
driver monitoring systems
and they can detect more than just drunk
drivers
some of them can keep an eye on your
eyes and figure out whether or not
you've got your eyes on the road
and or whether or not you're doing
proper scanning so that it knows that
you're consciously engaged in the
driving task
so these sorts of driver monitoring
systems are still quite rare
and they're really put only onto luxury
vehicles so the vast majority of
vehicles sold today
and for the foreseeable future aren't
going to help
yeah you know the only exposure i've had
to this kind of technology is there's
these
subaru ads right now where you know
parents are kind of worried about their
phone addicted teens out driving and
getting into these sort of horrific
accidents
parents have a way of imagining the
worst automakers are trying to
differentiate themselves with
the quality of their safety technology
[Music]
there's another one that honda did a
couple years ago
about a guy named mark mark is the best
husband and father you could ask for
who he's praised by lots of people great
guy
best man at my wedding he's got to keep
him off the dance floor
and then it shows mark crossing a street
and he's not really paying attention and
he's almost hit by
a honda but the honda uses its
pedestrian detection system
to spot him and the driver stops in time
pedestrian detection systems are one
version of sort of like a broad category
of safety technologies known
as advanced driver assistance systems or
eight ass
engaging green light oh my god
automatic emergency braking smart cruise
control or adaptive cruise control
lane assist all of those are a dash
systems
those are all important safety features
when you're thinking about
cars operating in higher speeds simpler
environments but
they are almost useless when you're
talking about vehicles that are
operating
in complicated urban environments triple
a did a study
recently showing that they're highly
suspect when
detecting a pedestrian at night
or when the vehicle is making a right
hand turn they do a really poor job
even detecting adult pedestrians only
detecting adult pedestrians
about 60 percent of the time and then
when it comes to
smaller pedestrians and and children
they they hardly detected them at all
in another study aaa also found that
other adas technology like lane assist
and adaptive
cruise control were simply unreliable
over 4 000 miles of driving researchers
encountered an issue about every eight
miles
and i assume this technology along with
any other technology it'll only get
better over time
but i'm curious with this technology
already out there who's really
pressuring these car companies to
improve it to make it better
as of now really no one this is all
voluntary work that's being done
by the automakers and some of them
really do invest a lot of money and
effort in it
some don't but it's really up to them
the shoulder belt and lap belt are now
combined
so that one buckle secures both belts
the reason
we have seat belts the reason we have
anti-lock brakes is because it was
mandated
by the government historically however
government action around safety
often faces backlash both by automakers
and drivers
it's always been a struggle to get
safety technology into automobiles
it took decades to make airbags which
are commonplace today
be mandatory in 1974
the federal government tried to impose
what's called a
a safety belt interlock so you couldn't
turn on your car
if you weren't wearing a safety belt and
within a year
auto interests and drivers were so irate
that they forced congress to backpedal
there's a long history of challenges
made sometimes from drivers
oftentimes from auto companies
themselves
multiple car makers and the automaker
lobbying group alliance for automotive
innovation declined to comment for the
story
the car is so entangled with american
ideas
of independence of freedom
and cars mean that to americans
the open road power
and rebellion nobody can tell you how to
drive or what to do
it's all about you and that i think
leads to
a real resistance among many people for
any sort of technology that it comes
across
as potentially limiting their freedom
even if it actually enhances
substantially the safety of other people
in society
you would not accept 299
737s which is crashing on an annual
basis
one plane crash crashing with that level
of
souls on it is not lost on society but
for some reason in the u.s
we don't focus don't pay attention to 38
000
road fatalities that it's not the human
cry
that it should be we're two things in
america we're a car
culture we love our cars and we love our
tech
people love technology at the end of the
day right so the challenge isn't the
engineering
the challenge is the political will of
getting these technologies on
every car so that we could take on the
nearly 40 000
lives lost every year and cut that about
in half
you